so if you look at each of these 4x6
grids it's pretty clear that there's 24
of these green circle things in each of
them but what I want to show you is that
you can get 24 is the product of three
numbers in multiple different ways and
it actually doesn't matter which
products you take first or what order
you actually do them in so let's think
about this first so the way that I've
colored it in I have these three groups
of four if you look at the blue
highlighting this is one group of four
two groups of four three groups of four
actually let me make it a little bit
clearer one group of four two groups of
four and three groups of four so these
three columns you could view as three
times four now we have another 3 times 4
right over here this is also 3 times 4
we have one group of 4 two groups of
four and three groups of four so you
could view these combined as two times
three times four we have one three times
four then we have another three times
four so the whole thing we could view as
the whole thing we could view as let me
get myself some more space as two times
let me do that in blue two times three
times four that's the total number of
balls here you can see it based on out
with how it was colored and of course if
you did three times four first you get
twelve and then you multiply that times
two you get 24 which is the total number
of these green circle things and I
encourage you now to look at these other
two pause the video and think about what
these would be the product of first
looking at the blue grouping then
looking at the purple grouping in the
same way that we did right over here and
verify that the product still equals 24
well I assume that you've paused the
video so you see here in this first in
this first I guess you could call it a
zone we have two groups of four so this
is 2 times 4 right over here we have one
group of 4 another group of 4 that's 2
times 4 we have one group of 4 another
group of 4 so this is also 2 times 4 if
we look in this purple zone one group of
4 another group before so this is also 2
times 4 so we have 3 2
times fours so if we look at each of
these are all together this is 3 times 2
times 4 so 3 times 2 times 4 2 times 4
notice I did a different order and I'm
and I'm here I did 3 times 4 first here
I'm doing 2 times 4 first but just like
before 2 times 4 is 8 8 times 3 is still
equal to 24 as it needs to because we
have exactly 24 of these green circle
things once again pause the video and
try to do the same here look at the
groupings in blue then look at the
groupings in purple and try to express
these 24 is a product of some kind of
product of 2 3 & 4
well you see first we have these
groupings of 3 so we have one grouping
of three in this purple zone two
groupings of three in this purple zone
so you could do that as 2 times 3 and we
have 1 3 and another 3 so in this purple
is oh this is another 2 times 3 we have
another 2 times 3 whoops I wrote 2 times
2 2 times 3 we have another 2 times 3 2
times 3 and then finally we have 1/4 2
times 3 so how many 2 times 3 do we have
here well we have 1 2 3 4 2 time threes
so this whole thing could be written as
could be written as 4 times 2 times 3 2
times 3 now what's this going to be
equal to well it needs to be equal to 24
and we can verify
2 times 3 is 6 times 4 is indeed 24 so
what the whole idea of what I'm what I'm
what I'm trying to show here is that the
order in which you multiply does not
matter how you associate it this is some
let me make this very clear so whether
you do let me pick a different example a
completely new example so let's say that
I have let's say that I have 4 times 5
times 6 you can do this multiplication
in multiple ways you could do 4 times 5
first or you could do 4 times
five times six first and you can verify
that I encourage you to pause the video
and verify that these two things are
equivalent and this is actually called
the associative property it doesn't
matter how you associate these things
which which of these that you do first
also order does not matter we've seen
that multiple multiple times whether you
do this or you do five times four times
six notice I swap the five and four this
doesn't matter whether you do this or
six times five times four doesn't matter
here I swap the six and the five times
four all of these are going to get the
exact same value and I encourage you to
pause the video so when we're talking
about which one we do first where we
were we which whether we do the 4 times
5 first or the 5 times 6 that's called
the associative property it's kind of a
fancy word for for a reasonably simple
thing and when we're saying that order
doesn't matter whether we're done it
doesn't matter whether we do 4 times 5
or 5 times 4 that's called the
commutative property and once again
fancy word for a very simple thing just
saying it doesn't matter what order I do
it in